la lutte contre la pandémie de covin 19
a mis au jour une nouvelle technique de
vaccins le vaccin à arn messager il
apparaît aujourd'hui comme le plus
fiable
ces fameux vaccin arn messagers ont été
produits par deux laboratoires pfizer
green tech et modern a désormais dans le
monde entier tous les laboratoires
cherchent à produire leur propre vaccin
ar alors la rm messager pourrait-il a
révolutionné la médecine
on y répond dans facture pour comprendre
comment fonctionne la rn message et il
faut d'abord comprendre quelle est sa
fonction chez l'homme le corps humain
est composé de cellules chacune des
cellules contient dans son noyau tout le
patrimoine génétique dans ce que l'on
appelle la dnc l'adn qui est à l'origine
de la production des protéines dont les
cellules ont besoin pour fonctionner
pour fabriquer une protéine la cellule
génère une copie à l'usagé unique de
l'adn qui est en fait la recette de la
production de la protéine c line
messager une fois la protéine produite
la rn très fragile et détruit l'adn sera
libre dans une bibliothèque chacune de
nos cellules à ce livre qui a toutes les
recettes la rn le collier à une seule
rangée est une copie de quelques pages
d'une page du livre donc les cellules
copie quelques pages du livre et donc
ont quelques arn qui code pour quelques
protéines et ensuite vous avez les
protéines qui font la sanction de la
part de la cellule quand protéines vous
connaissez tous par exemple la solide
cette molécule transitoire a été
découverte en france en 1961 par trois
chercheurs français de l'institut
pasteur
récompensé par le prix nobel de médecine
la rn est une molécule fragile ce qui
explique son exploitation termine mais
avec l'apparition du cope 19
les recherches en cours déjà depuis
plusieurs années se sont accélérées
alors le vaccin arm qu'est ce que c'est
le principe reste le même qu'en accents
classiques
il s'agit de confronter le système
immunitaire à une simulation d'infection
pour le préparer à se défendre
le sar skov de virus ducobu 19 et
tentures et d'une membrane sur laquelle
est fixée une protéine la protéine spike
dans un vaccin classique on emporte le
virus inactivé ou atténué de façon à
entraîner le système immunitaire a
résisté dans un vaccin arn on introduit
la rn messager pur dans notre corps
autrement dit on introduit la recette de
la protéine spahic cet arn messagers
synthétique va permettre la production
de la protéine directement dans le corps
de la personne vaccinée en fabriquant la
protéine
le corps se débarrasse de la rn et le
système immunitaire s'habituer à
reconnaître la protéine et à la
combattre dans les vaccins classiques
certains adjuvants sont nécessaires pour
déclencher une réponse immunitaire
suffisante comme les sels d'aluminium
par exemple alors que dans ces vaccins
la rm messager pur suffit autre avantage
de la rn on note à ce jour peu d'effets
indésirables comparé aux autres vaccins
alors au delà du coc u19 en quoi cette
nouvelle technique peut-elle
révolutionné la médecine
d'abord il ya les vaccins anti cancer
qui sont développés aussi principalement
pas pour ça il n'est pas une tech qui
sont en face deux cures bakar aussi
beaucoup développer des vaccins anti
cancer sans réussir à le valider pour
l'instant mais si on t'a qu'utilise une
autre méthodologie donc cette approche
est très prometteuse
dans ce cas le système immunitaire
réagit contre les protéines autour de la
tumeur
il ne détruit que les cellules malades
et laisse les cellules saines
contrairement aux chimiothérapies qui
détruisent à la fois les cellules saines
et les cellules malades
la rm usagers pourraient aussi être
utilisés dans des vaccins contre
d'autres virus et contre des allergies
l'avantagé que c'est plus facile de
produire un arn encore que pour lui un
anticorps et dans ces cas là aussi c'est
votre corps qui produit la protéine dont
quels étaient les meilleurs il ya moins
de contaminants donc vous pouvez
remplacer les produits existants ou
partie des produits existants par des
agrafes synthétique et effectivement ça
ouvre beaucoup de joie pour produire de
nouveaux produits en médecine grâce à
leurs aînés c'est dans sa boutique
autre utilisation possible de la rn
message et l'usagé thérapeutique contre
des maladies inflammatoires
dégénératives ou chroniques
il pourrait être un remède contre des
maladies létale comme la mucoviscidose
par exemple dans tous les cas la rn
messager vient apporter la protéine
fonctionnelle à des patients dont le
système dysfonctionnements par exemple
il ya moderna qui est en face d'eux pour
re croître des vaisseaux sanguins dans
le coeur donc après un infarctus disons
quand vous avez une zone du coeur qui
n'est plus irrigué de vous pouvez
injecter de la haine messager qui va
stimuler la croissance de vaisseaux
sanguins pour ré irriguer la somme qui
n'a plus de vaisseau il deviendrait
possible de donner à nos cellules
une nouvelle fonction de cicatrisation
d'amélioration qui serait éphémère
là est tout l'intérêt de la rn mais
s'agit il est à la fois suffisant pour
pallier certains dysfonctionnements et
sécurisés dans la mesure où il ne
perdure pas dans notre corps on pourrait
même imaginer utiliser sept
technique au delà du domaine médical
pour remédier au vieillissement de la
peau par exemple
par exemple vous voyez donc notre peau
donc produit de l'élastine jusqu'à du
codé à la fin d'adolescence au début de
l'âge adulte et nos produits purs après
donc si vous injecter de la rn codant
pour l'élastine vous pouvez réexprimer
l'élastine dans la peau par exemple du
pire hâtif et l'esthétique les champs
d'applications potentielles sont très
variées est une petite révolution
mais mais mais ce qui est très
intéressant c'est de voir à quel point
les crises en fait son show permettent
le développement de l'innovation la
crise sanitaire
aa été un levier fantastique pour
arriver à pousser cette innovation qui
était de max m2 de la phase de
conception dont on a pas d'application
les vaccins sont aujourd'hui sûr et
efficace
ils ne sont pas pour autant une solution
miracle il s'agit des essais vaccinaux
les plus rapides de l'histoire de la
science est par définition aucun recul
du possible mais il est clair qu'ils
sont porteurs de beaucoup d'espoirs pour
l'avenir de la science
[Musique]